aujourd'hui on va choisir jeunes
super-héros moi aussi j'ai envie de vous
parler de ce père héros et quelques
tours j'étais vraiment à fond dans des
comics de super-héros mais là je me suis
dit en fait que pour les héros à venir
avec qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire en fait
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire tous les
pouvoirs style et ont déjà été pris
alors il va rester que des pouvoirs un
peu un peu naze même vraiment un sport
du coup ceux qui veulent créer des super
héros maintenant comment ils vont faire
pour pas de faire traiter de plagiat et
bien voici la réponse de la question
fait appris hier qu'elle est trop mal je
t'aurais prévenu qu'est ce qui m'arrive
quel sorcellerie utilises tu donnes tu
succombera sous les effets de la pire
musique de l'univers non regarde
thilleman où tu va mordre la poussière
je sais que ça c'est ton troll était
génial
j'illustre avec la chanson go
armées csfa 3,6 marie picque de
super-héros mois en lozère et norman
nous fait aujourd'hui le décès de
benomad dont le sort a été impitoyable
le monde s'est excusé ensuite ré
aujourd'hui sur une justice alors là je
viens à peine de lancer le mode solo que
vous me rejoignent et déjà n'est ce pas
beau alors on va essayer d'un petit peu
sur l'histoire
donc j'ai déjà joué au jeu mais pas chez
moi et c'était en mode arcade avec avec
des amis donc ce n'était pas vraiment le
mode solo chez absolument pas comment
est le mode solo mais au premier combat
qu'on aura l'occasion de faire je vous
décris est un petit peu le jeu est un
petit peu mon avis là dessus en tout cas
j'espère que l'intro vous aura plu et en
aidant c'est parti tout est cassé alors
oh la vache
donc la ville est un peu morte
apparemment breaking news d'accord
metropolis détruites des millions de
morts
d'accord
quand même la bombe nucléaire a explosé
en bas à droite j'ai vu waouh
alors pour ceux qui savent pas une
justice que c'est c'est un petit jeu de
combat un peu comme tekken mortal kombat
street fighter et cetera sauf que ça
porte sur l'univers dc et l'univers dc
c'est à dire batman le joker et c'est
alors juste là pour les cinématiques
c'est très mal modélisés la vache mais
je vais vous dire que les séquences de
gameplay ce sera autre chose logique où
tu l'as eu pourquoi tu en veux waouh
alors attendez je vais juste me mettre
en
superman arrive superbe elle est dans
les bacs toi tu es je laisse moi j'ai
fait de belles oies il est pas content
tu maroc d'abord krypton puis il met
d'accord de carmine nul au fond de
tendance sur metropolis c'est pas vrai
superman non que que labatt souris
auxquelles ces bouffées une table mail
gmail est alors est-ce qu'on va donc
faire le premier combat entre les deux
ça serait cool moi je pense vous trouvez
pas tu penses pouvoir avoir une famille
comme enfermé va me changer comme par
magie au pire à quel sera mon sécuri aux
absa d'accord j'ai le plaisir c'est
vraiment juste pour montrer le sait pas
on espère donc juste vous montrer tout
ça alors voilà là on est donc en phase
de combat alors c'est parti on va taper
donc on a donc plusieurs fours pour les
défoncer up notamment à les matins alors
je pense pas que ça va être très dur
veut qu'on est au tout début du jeu à
moins que remarque au revoir au revoir
voilà donc alors les spécificités du jeu
du je suis un peu là pour moi pour
montrer un petit peu at war comme le jeu
en fait en fin de compte alors
premièrement le truc hyper qui pendant
ce jeu c'est qu'on peut interagir avec
le décor alors fixé le mode solo
je ne sais pas trop si on peut le faire
encore non apparemment peut pas
voilà alors ça par contre c'est un truc
du jeu
c'est à dire que dans une map si vous
voulez il ya plusieurs maps est donc là
il m'a envoyé plusieurs parties de la
maaf et là il m'a envoyé dans la seconde
partie de la matte en me mettant donc
assez cher en fait le niveau difficulté
alors quand même un petit peu hardcore
et on a des coups spéciaux like that qui
se développe au bout d'un certain nombre
de concours humaines de psa s'est pas
tarder of john hyams hélas en mode on a
un petit peu des gens qui ont la classe
2 voilà donc c'était un petit peu ça
c'est un petit peu sympa c'est à dire
que là lui aussi là son attaque spéciale
ce que vous pouvez voir on va s'agrippa
luxe avec quoi parce qu'on aime bien
alors quoi d'autre ma foi est-ce qu'on
va devoir le bateau n'a pas de
thématique ou un truc cette fois non
alors au wa lâ ilâha interagit avec le
décor mm et un coup de coude un coup de
porc in the gun à mais il est tellement
chiant ce mec bon attendez ce serait
bien qu'on gagne donc là en fait si vous
voulez comment ça se passera pas
pilleurs ont de quoi comme dans la route
notamment
c'est vraiment du un seul combat canton
tout le truc
sauf que le si le combat va durer aussi
longtemps c'est que si vous voulez vous
avez deux barres de vie donc là
actuellement on est tous deux sur notre
deuxième et il se trouve que ces deux
bars des comptes que les combats durent
a si longtemps alors ah bon certains
peuvent trouver s'ennuyant mois pour le
coup je n'ai rien à [ __ ] que ce soit
l'emploi
je vais vous montrer comment ici on peut
parler cet homme alors quand il faut dès
qu'ils jouent au hockey il nous avait
son attaque spéciale
on va prendre très très cher macquart
qu'écoutent john wooden et paint the
faith parfois c'est la fête mitraillage
tabasser c'est cool quand la vie est
belle vous savez quoi
on est plus malin que lui voilà l
batmobile
alors je pense qu'on va lâcher sur ses
vêtements ouais oh le coup de gbagbo
pam il est mort donc voilà alors après
avoir interagit avec le port cinéma fois
je vous donne donc deux trois choses on
pense déjà que le décor on peut on peut
utiliser ses compétences la spéciale et
à et puis en jeu si vous voulez on peut
faire deux trois coaches peu spéciaux
contenant une part plus rapidement cette
barre donc et qu elle est remplie nous
permet de faire cette compétence mais ça
donne un petit peu compliqué mais bon en
gros ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
c'est un jeu de combat avec les
personnages de dc universe donc ce que
vous voyez là superwomen destroy lui
c'est green lantern version méchant j'ai
raté de son nom et puis tout ça pour moi
c'est vraiment ça qui en gros qui m'a
fait il m'a fait prendre le jeu le
régiment font un petit peu avec lui
comment il s'appelle larcher qui a c'est
assez rapide époux gp son nom mais il
est marrant ce personnage est marrant
pour l'arrangeur que vous dire qu'il est
sympa colère le défaut du jeu c'est
vraiment les cinématiques qui sont
dégueulasses
mais vraiment dégueulasse au niveau du
gameplay ça va c'est cool façon lui
chez bon les fraudes jeu de combat me
diront non mais moi j'ai un petit peu
l'impression que ça se ressemble bref on
suit l'histoire va pouvoir jouer c'est
l'homme des stalles catwoman à l'ofce
plus qui sait bayne l'aïe appelle jamais
katana je serai plus c'est une île
explique or rompre ça c'est vraiment la
fight quoi je sais que mon avion qui
sont encore au travail
d'accord batman serait d'ailleurs
parlant espagnol est ce tu fais là moi
je t'ai boîte tu vois alors les
compétences spéciales que je vous dis je
voulais montrer vite fait c'est ça non
pas ça absolument pas en l an passé
comment ils sont bas les couilles de
natation ben tu le tjp eux tu vas voulu
me chatouiller on peut faire des
apparemment hop
ah [ __ ] voilà la xac d'envoyer un
petit peu dans le décor envoyé on
interagit vraiment j'aimerais juste vous
montrer en lui on peut pas choper tient
la bonne souris gamer c'est donc lui
apparemment le défoncer à dommage
albatar il a fait remettre dedans
qu'est ce que tu fais en foire et de
berne [ __ ] mais j'arrive pas à tout
faire les six wilayas compétences
spéciales voilà la glissade par terre
celles ci n'ont eux
alors voilà cette petite animation
signifie qu'il a perdu une barre de vie
bref je pense que vous avez un petit peu
tous sur le gameplay ni vos compétences
on peut aussi s'agripper à lui s'il ne
faisait pas vers le haut comme un
discours mois la jeune star ça ça donc
les chiffres quelques jours d'envoyer ça
ça augmente la barre en bas bref
ban vient de battre y abattre sur non au
thé sur tes sur ok tu l'aurais voulu
au revoir l'aide au bac en histoire et
il a contré le truc non on peut
retrouver un petit peu voulait
apparemment alors du coup j'ai un petit
peu mais à coutances dans le vide tu peu
dégoûté mais bon elle et comment on les
reconnaît merde arbitres non [ __ ] il
m'a envoyé de l'autre côté de la map où
c'est serré c'est corsé
c'est sympa ces petites animations
pendant
[ __ ] tu ce que ça m'a enlevé de vie
ouais c'est ça ouais fetaf soit tombé
toi mais [ __ ] il m'énerve et il est
moche comme un tueur plus belle
voilà moi aussi je t'envoie de notre
côté gauche de cours je suis un mec je
t'envoie dans la stratosphère carrément
et bim tu te prends un ovni de star wars
troisième partie de la map le savent
bien
merde bâtard non c'est ce que je voulais
faire aux îles mais trop cher
j'aime pas ça un wargame voilà c'est bon
cette fois en live c'est nous mais la
scène on est mort alors valait bien
qu'on le mette la main au petit mail
mais que c'est chez blizzard hop voilà
sinon j'espère qu'un jour vous ne
croiserez jamais b doman fin benomad un
peu inutile mais surtout music man et
batman ce redoutable ben catwoman
grandis tu es tout seul
luthor les génies le sont souvent les
psychopathes dans ton genre le héros
vous êtes tous les mêmes c'est encore
moins impressionnant de près alors on va
se battre contre l'ex des limites c'est
cool ça ya vraiment de la tap un [ __ ]
des débuts merde s'appuie sur six
d'après chiant à jouer ta crustin j'y
tiens merde j'ai rappelé sur bxl [ __ ]
ils alternent au maire bernard
ok je suis mort d'accord on se bat
contre l'ex
mais qu on l'a stoppé net sa bulle
vilain alors je connais pas encore les
combos mais ils sont un petit peu dures
batailles se protègent bien en plus
assez ça pour protéger je vous
remonterez reste avec moi ok bah pas
taper pas où je faisais c'est génial
enfin pour pour se protéger et vient
contrer le méridien là par contre je les
fais c'est dégueulasse up alors [ __ ]
c'est vraiment dur sata on va les voir
la gueule
ok ok ce qu'on peut pas lui faire un
tueur ikken couture week-end parce que
femme je connais tellement pas les
combats encore c'est assez ouf non
bâtard prends toi je sais que tu aimes
bien les robots nom est moi [ __ ] mais
il est trop long tiens maintenant il va
venir vers nous ah oui moi je rigole je
rigole mort non il m'appelait sauté
dessus
thion
on a quand même bien éclaté tiens up
espèce de espace de chambre tu vas
mourir le chauffe face aux grands chocs
de malades chez qui on peut faire des
combos ce coup mais je suis pas les
faire en fait bon allez on le finit en
beauté avec la batmobile mère je vais
pas encore merde sans quelques couches
d'eau voilà j'aurai peut-être à on gagne
de l'xp je crois que c'est steve va me
servir à débloquer des tenues en tout
cas pour nos super héros
j'ai peut être sympa et peut-être des
yeux mais je suis pas sûr du tout
superman au rapport c'est terminé toi
non mais c'est si le et quand ils vont
en tout ils sont pas braqués contre la
conte la bagnole de police non qu'est ce
que c'est ils font braquer que le
portail radiologique métropolis qui se
passe je vois juste qu'avec par les
cousins les justiciers échoue le clown
massacre a donné ça me passionne moi
j'adore tellement dc et marvel si vous
voulez que de superman sa course est
sorti un jeu comme ça des cje combat
c'est sympa on avait bien sûr pc c'etait
dc universe online fans de rpg c'était
assez bien de segi mexique ou encore
jacques rocher pas énormément bon après
deux semaines on s'est un petit peu
chier dans le jeu même après à quelques
jours alors que l'un jeu de combat c'est
sympa ça change de dégâts street fighter
etc c'est cool
elle trop marrante avec une retourne
dans le van hamme et batman et moi avons
parlé eux
sos maltraitance des phoques tués sans
et qui la sépare de ma page qui ferait
une bonne manche 1 contre et je savais
que ce nas d'edf ce troc ne t'aurais par
année dommage pour toi qu'est-ce qui te
prends je n'ai qu'à la m et c'est de ce
bouton que tu dois te méfier
et voilà il bluffe me lavisse curé pas
aux flashs et les green lanterns
c'est quand même super si les ja va et
vient vraiment tu as puis il y aura 8
millions de morts 8 millions de la mine
je voulais profiter de ce petit feu
d'artifice à bonne distance
mais puisque tu es mort m'accorderez
dieu cette dernière temps
avec la musique épique autre style l
objectif
oh qu'est ce qui s'est passé a dit en
fait c'est un gros bluff s'ajuster les
porter avec lui non je sais pas oui un
petit bug sur le panneau amis c'est fait
exprès qu'est ce qui cloche avec cette
prime
j'ai pas compris si c'est parce que
sincèrement de ta faute
c'est sa vraie métropolis et pourtant il
sait trop à se battre les jokers
remballe ta caisse trop sentimentale
sans toi ah on est passé en mode games
sas voie directe c'est parti ol et rossi
avec son couteau hop
non mais non mais austère début de
combat assez bof bof au gardien
ouah tiens tiens dégage [ __ ] mais
comment j'espère avoir le ou les chiens
du requin de merde [ __ ] mais casse toi
et ton venin l'accent ton coeur salaires
efficace et techniciens
ah il m'énerve or il était en plus ses
coups ils sont super rageant oh [ __ ]
oh lala com en haut c'est pas possible
toi mon gars mais mais je te met un high
kick [ __ ] coup de tête balayette
voilà c'est ça qu'on veut tient alors le
jeu par contre il est vraiment pas
facile à prendre en main parce qu'on
peut pas la voir comme ça et à son live
heureusement d'ailleurs
il est vraiment répugnant joker il est
vraiment mais certains personnages
trouvent ok on a vu est ce qu'on fera
chauffer la voiture là aux habitants on
pouvait mais c'est quand même et c'est
passé tiens j'ai accompli en bêta ok
donc c'est ça me protège du tout montré
si j'arrive bien à il attend à d'accord
ok d'accord je vois il attendra
l'enfoiré aux rémois ah oui c'est vrai
qu'on peut faire ça je me souvenais même
plus tiens hormis cela il est trop fort
le caillou pour le prof j'en suis sûr
troll
ok on peut pas penser qu'ils ont
derrière vraiment le populaire tient
bien
on plonge dans votre petit jeu des
cordes on laisse moi le terme
archi plus que l'on fait aux non pas
celui qui l'a mené en voyez vous allez
voir oh là là là là hop c'est quoi ça
waouh
la vache olala c'est comme ça tu y
compris mais c'était assez assez stylé
j'ai gagné un choc apparemment ça va
être content tu m'aimes quand même temps
détagage pas bon charbon à coke est un
bâtard tiens tiens oh oui c'est comme ça
hein non j'aurais pu lui enlever de
l'autre côté zut
bon on a dépensé joker e bouge plus ça
me glace et mécène qui les a je crois
trop que la police arrive
est ce qu'il y aura le
je vais devoir pur voilà ça
alors que va-t-il faire un petit hélico
qui va aller chercher le bas de cocktail
à non il a dit parlait pas de trucs 1
s'il vous plaît pas de trucs qu'il a dit
voilà merci la police bon
[Musique]
à
pour la fage
ah oui assez plutôt radical je vous
prête les oreilles et je vous de gaz
on voit les gens écouter cette vidéo
prend à sa fin si vous l'avez l'histoire
c'est parce que je me serais arrêté là
comme je dis souvent si vous voulez
d'autres vidéos sur dc universe sur un
peu l'histoire ya pas de souci demandez
moi un commentaire et puis voilà on se
retrouve dans une nouvelle vidéo chat ou
le monde pis
[Musique]
ce jeu est plus rageante tout simplement
que fit pas les colosses réunis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]